[Evans] Now we're ready for a quiz to see if you understand the goal of the hash table.
The question is, if we have b buckets in our hash table
and we have k keywords--and we should assume that k is much greater than b,
that there are more keywords than we have buckets--
the question is, which of the properties should the hash function have?
And remember what the hash function is.
It's a function that takes in a keyword,
produces a number, and what that number does is gives us the position in the hash table
which is the bucket where that keyword would appear.
The first choice is output a unique number between 0 and k - 1,
so each keyword maps to its own output number.
The second choice is output a number between 0 and b - 1
the number of buckets that we have.
The third choice is it should map approximately k/b of the keywords to bucket 0.
That means for that number of keywords
the output of the hash should be 0 and it should map to the first bucket.
The fourth choice is map approximately k/b of the keywords to bucket b - 1.
That's the last bucket.
And the final choice is it should map more of the keywords to bucket 0
than it maps to bucket 1.
Check all of the properties that we would like the hash function to have.